Hello and welcome to the nerd writer
podcast movie review edition.
This is the first podcast that I'm
attempting to do.
I love podcasts.
I love listening to them.
I just think there's something special
about them.
I love audio.
I love really great audio love listening
to the human voice when it's nice
clothes.
Nice and close to a really good mic.
So I'm going to try a podcast here.
I just got out of the movie looper and I
want to talk about that today.
I'm not going to do percentages.
Can do rotten tomatoes for that.
Not going to do stars.
You can do Roger Ebert for that.
I just want to talk about the movie and
I think that I do have the
qualifications to talk about movies
because I was a film student.
I know a little bit about what goes into
making a movie.
I've tried writing short films.
I even tried a getting my hand trying to
do a feature a couple of years ago.
It didn't work out,
but I at least know what it takes,
so I have all that.
Much more respect for Ryan Johnson,
the director of looper and writer who
composed this time travel story.
Oh,
and I want to mention before I start,
I haven't read anything about this.
I haven't seen any reviews,
haven't read any reviews.
I don't know what rotten tomatoes even
gave it,
which is strange for me.
I usually always check before I go.
I know what some friends have said and
the reviews have been in the all in the
range of good,
some really good,
some great,
some luke warm,
but still mostly positive,
so I really enjoyed it.
I had a great time watching the movie,
the experience of watching.
It was a lot of fun.
The first,
the first half hour to an hour of the
movie I thought was just flawless
storytelling really quick.
Getting all the information out there
that you need.
The world that they're living in.
Twenty,
44 is explained in the process of the
story.
Future movies that are set in the future
can sometimes get caught up in
explaining the world that they're living
in.
I don't think that looper falls into
that trap.
I think that the elements of the future,
the future technologies that you're
showing,
the way that the world is,
are done as a,
as sort of a side glance to the story
proper.
And I think that the world is very
interesting.
There's a few sort of technological
changes that you see,
things that you might expect.
Nothing too ridiculous,
but also you get the sense that this is
a dystopian future.
The 20,
44 of this world is something has gone
wrong in the period of time in between.
And maybe it's something terrible has
gone wrong.
They've,
I think they make one reference to the
vagrant raids of the something.
Something so governments or the ability
to police whatever city that this story
is set in a sort of broken down a little
bit.
Seems like the crime bosses have control
of the town.
People are getting shot,
you know,
out near buses for whatever reason
because you know,
they're trying to steal something.
Um,
so it's not a place that you'd maybe
want to live unless that is,
you were a looper.
And I think that the character of the
loopers very interesting.
And I'm realizing things as I,
as I just thinking about this movie,
having seen it,
which I think is going to happen in the
next couple of days,
which I,
which is a mark of a good movie.
One of the things is that these loopers
are people who are not really thinking
about their future,
right?
They go to the same bar every day.
They get paid for their job,
killing people from the future,
and they're doing the same drugs.
You know when I was for those,
for those of us went to college,
I used to call this the haze.
You just do the same things over and
over again and it felt like frankly a
loop right the same night,
the same weekend over and over again.
You lose track of time.
You lose track of yourself.
I think that is something that the
loopers in this movie are definitely
going through,
symbolized by the fact that one of the
key elements is something called closing
the loop where the bosses in the future
of somehow deemed it cleaning their own
hands of loose ends.
They've sent back these kid loopers when
they're older,
30 years in the future to kill
themselves.
You don't know that it's going to be
them because they're bagged on the head,
but these kids,
these loopers don't,
they really don't have a future.
They have 30 years and that's it.
So there's a layer there.
There's a subtext there of are these
people's lives anything more than what
they do?
The montage in the beginning does a lot
of that for you.
Um,
and the way that the drug,
for example,
this drop in your eyes filmed,
it's just really,
really stylistic and smart and I think
that is something that is shown
throughout the whole movie.
But moving on.
Oh,
and I probably should mention there's
going to be spoilers in this.
So if you haven't seen it,
I'd say stop listening right now and go
out and see it.
It is worth your money to say,
so things start to get a little bit more
intense,
more serious.
When Joseph [inaudible] character played
by Bruce will lets his future self comes
back to the past and they show in a
montage of the years intervening what
happens to him.
He goes to China,
does some more killing,
but then eventually falls in love with
this Asian woman who he says saves some,
saves them from this life.
Now there's potentially troubling thing
in this to begin with,
which is the fact that Joseph Horne
Levitt is a murderer.
He's murdered people who he doesn't know
that they've done something bad.
Even if we cited that murdering people
was okay.
It doesn't know that it doesn't mean
bad.
He's just taking.
He's taking the word of the bosses in
the future that they want them dead so
he doesn't.
It's,
it's,
it's hard already to sympathize with him
in the beginning.
That will become much,
much harder for the Bruce Willis
character later in the movie,
but we'll get to that.
The main criticism I have with time
travel movies and this movie is that
depending on what the movie is,
you can sort of get a sense.
You get the feeling towards the end that
the movie is trying to figure itself
out.
Time travel.
Movies are so much about the writing of
them is so much about closing all the
loop,
the loose ends,
making sure that it logical,
that it works right,
especially ones that are explicitly
about time travel,
like Lupron.
Now of course,
you can't close out every loose end with
time travel movies.
We always take things for granted.
For example,
we know that it's not logical that only
small things would change for the
future.
Bruce Willis,
when little things change in the
presence of the movie,
when he cuts his arm,
we know that little moments in the
future affect big consequences or
lithium is in the president effect big
consequences in the future.
The,
the,
the butterfly effect,
the chaos effects.
So all of these things being at being at
that bar to meet that Asian woman who
eventually marries those things don't
happen after.
It's a little thing like a,
just a small misstep in the,
in,
in another direction.
Um,
happens.
But we let those things go.
And time travel movies,
because if we didn't,
we wouldn't be able to have time travel
movies.
It just wouldn't work.
Right.
I'm back to the future of great time
travel movie.
The the picture disappearing thing is,
you know when,
when when their existence becomes
questionable,
they disappear in the picture.
That is ridiculous,
but because it's like it goes from the
head goes from the head down to the,
the,
the feet,
the last thing that they have.
That's just ridiculous,
but we let it go because we know that
some liberties have to be taken and it's
a good example that these two movies are
good,
are good to compare against each other
because the time travel elements in back
to the future are very campy to begin
with and it's a very campy movie and
back to the future spends a lot of time
on the character and the story in the
past.
Have Marty and the parents and all that
stuff.
Even though time travel is the wrapping
that is all around it.
Looper is one of these movies in the
line of inception,
dark knight,
the Chris Nolan type of movies where
everything has to be sort of airtight,
watertight,
right?
This is really realistic.
This is what would happen.
This is how it would be.
My main criticism of looper and in that
vein is that you feel at the end of the
movie,
the time travel elements of the story
spinning themselves to their proper
conclusion,
and that for me takes away from the
character development,
which which for a great movie is always,
always the center of the story.
I'm not to say that there aren't great
characters in this movie.
I think that Joseph Gordon Levitt,
Bruce Willis a and emily blunt,
do great acting jobs for their
characters,
but there are a few things that sort of
go wonky in the third act first,
when Bruce Willis kills that kid,
whatever sympathy you had for him
immediately goes what we know from Ryan
Johnson,
the director's choice early on,
that the fact that he doesn't show Elma,
emily blunt's child's face the first
three times we see him.
We know that he's the rainmaker.
That's something that I don't think he's
trying to hide from us.
Um,
and the fact that we know that means
that the first kid that Bruceville's
skills is an innocent child,
and even though he feels remorse about
it afterwards,
it's hard for us to sympathize with
Bruceville's.
Again,
I don't know if that's Ryan will ryan or
Ryan Johnson's attention for us
sympathize,
but we don't do it after that.
Excuse me.
Taking a drink here.
And then we have that almost.
What essentially is Bruce Willis becomes
John mcclane from die hard and starts
ripping people apart with machine guns
and semiautomatic guns.
Just killing scores and scores of
people.
This guy,
his last two are empathetic urges,
right?
He can't get what he wants.
You cannot build a love so strong to
justify for the viewer the murder that
he commits in the end of that movie.
And,
and I,
like I said before,
it's already hard with Joseph Gordon
Levitt character.
Oh,
and one thing,
by the way that I mentioned that I had
noticed that I don't think the person
who was watching it with notice,
um,
which I thought was interesting little
thing,
uh,
so the punk kid who's got the Gat,
who really shouldn't be allowed to have
any kind of gun because he is
ridiculous.
That's Jeff Daniels from the future,
from,
from the president.
That's Jeff Daniels past self.
I think the way that you can tell,
the way that I noticed it was when Jeff
Daniels died and he's sort of looking at
him really sad.
The next thing he sees on the wall is
the map where Joseph Gordon Levitt is,
and there's a circle on the map and I
think that is supposed to symbolize
closing the loop.
So,
well done,
Ryan Johnson on that.
That was a good little moment.
I think I'm reading about that.
I could be wrong.
So when Joseph Gordon Levitt,
kills himself in the end and is able to
change the rainmakers future to become
it,
presumably he's going to become good
now.
Whatever him.
The process,
the,
the moment of him killing himself to me,
felt unsatisfying.
The reason was because I felt the time
travel elements overshadowing the
character elements.
There had to be an end to this story
that worked for eight.
A fallen character like Joseph Gordon
Levitt,
killing yourself is really the only way
to go.
First of all.
So you already have that.
Second of all,
what happens,
you know,
Bruce Willis cannot be made to get back
with the Asian woman.
His wife,
Joseph Levitt isn't going to go on to
live with emily blunt and the kid.
Right?
So this is really the only ending of the
movie that there could be.
And there are a lot of really great
movies I should mention that have fallen
characters,
lowlife characters,
but it's broadcast very early on about
those characters that they won't make
it.
And you know it a good distance from the
end.
The fact that Ryan Johnson tries to keep
us in suspense,
like maybe Joseph Gordon Levitt might
make it,
I think actually takes away from the
movie because it would be a sort of.
I think it just would be an empty
feeling if he got to live.
I think that's the trap the movie gets
into.
It would be an empty feeling for the
viewer.
If he got to live,
it's hard to redeem that kind of
character,
but he didn't make him a tragic
character early on,
early enough in the movie.
So you're sort of vacillating between
the two sides.
Will he make it?
Well,
that's not going to feel great,
but he's not telling me that he's not
going to make it.
So that's really my main criticism of
the movie is that the characters are
subsumed by the plot elements of making
a time travel story work.
All that said,
really,
really enjoyable movie.
I mean,
one thing that was fantastic sound
editing sound mixing.
Wow,
amazing.
I don't know who did it,
but you did a great job and you should
be nominated for an Oscar because I
thought that the way that the story
moved along with sound was brilliant and
despite the problems I had with the end
of it,
it just that that really just precludes
it from becoming a great movie from a
really,
really good movie.
So I think that if you haven't seen it,
which would be ridiculous at this point
because I've spoiled all of it,
but if you haven't,
go see it,
it's worth the money to go.
See.
That's the review I have of looper.
I hope you enjoyed it.
Hope it wasn't too long and if you want,
if you leave,
please leave any comments what you think
about this.
If you want me to do more of them,
it's a lot of fun and I will see you
next time.